the problem for depp again is once you
marry her
she she uh
she pooped in his bed
i mean
oh yeah incredible oh yeah we didn't
talk about amber turd yet did we yeah
there was uh there was a turd that she
decided to lay
on johnny depp's side of the bed after
he left due to the conflict when she was
beating him you know purportedly he went
to one of his condos in hollywood and
just stayed there and uh i think he said
somebody had to notify him that there
was a a turd on his bed
and um
you know the uh somebody in the trial
said well how do you know it wasn't like
one of the dogs he's like well i've
picked up yorkie's [ __ ] before it's
quite small like this was human
right
uh i had a case a long time ago where
the guy
was a car guy and he bought and he
ordered a uh
911 targa it's a porsche car i think the
middle roof somehow came off yeah right
so he gets this car and he's going to a
wedding with his wife of like maybe 18
months or a year and he had a rule like
nobody can drink anything in the car
unless it's bottled water i don't want
anything else in the car he really
it was like his prized possession
and
he's driving to a wedding they're
fighting and she
reaches into her handbag and she opens
up a thing a nail polish and she starts
to polish her nails in his car
and not only did that really tick him
off but the fumes really gave him a
headache
long story short that was the last time
he filed for divorce like a week and a
half later it was building to that and
she was so passive aggressive toward him
and she knew it would hurt him and she
knew the smell bothered him and she knew
she was in his prized possession i had
camel collar seats if i remember right
she had this red nail polish
she didn't spill any but he was unnerved
by it to the point of saying
that's got that's not right and he
realized the correct thing to do in that
scenario gentlemen is
pull over get the [ __ ] out
right there it doesn't matter where it
is get the f when she crosses the bottom
line that you've set
especially with something that matters
to you like your car
speaking as a car guy obviously get the
[ __ ] out that's it
so uh you know she did
that's that came to mind when i when i
heard that is that as bad as pooping in
a bed it's pretty close yeah you know
that kind of passive aggressive just
sick
to do that to somebody that you
allegedly love
ah he best move he ever made uh his
whole life changed for the better after
that
um
all right heard pathologically defensive
and blame-shifting
like just to see her understand talk
about how she lived the life with johnny
and
and all this was his fault she just
can't put a whole sentence together that
makes any sense i can't imagine what the
transcript of that case is going to read
like with her stopping and starting and
bringing in extraneous words and
extraneous things that happen it just
woes me i'm the victim he's all at fault
no one's going to buy that i don't think
the jury's going to buy it either so
um there's a note here sorry i'm not
sure if we glossed over it but heard
refused to sign a prenup or post up like
it was a complete refusal
yeah from what i've been able to
ascertain
anyway
big time
yeah and
now this guy's got good lawyers he's got
business managers
uh he's been in relationships before
what was he thinking he's got kids yeah
he's got kids
what was he thinking and i saw a
testimony from
uh
one of his witnesses i think his
financial guy that said her original
demand was five million and then she
wanted five million five hundred
thousand then she wanted six million
then she wanted seven million and when
he said yes to the seven million then i
want him to take a hundred percent of
the 13 and a half million dollar debt
uh all of it i don't want to have to
deal with any of that debt that was yeah
i heard that but any debt that was
accrued during the marriage is a marital
debt so if he owed money for whatever
and she's spending over 100 grand a
month on wine
uh so she didn't want to have to deal
with any of that
but i've seen that in cases where you
get a narcissist on the other side
they'll make a demand and then they
never stop so we say look no that's the
uh if that's your uh demand this is what
we'll do if not it's going to go to
trial
because it never ends didn't johnny
depp's former
lovers or wives all step forward and i
don't know swear an affidavit or
something to the effect that they were
never abused by him they never had any
domestic violence issues he wasn't
abusive or anything like that
yeah that would be useful in the trial
i don't know if a judge would let now
remember hearsay is an out of court
statement made to prove the truth of the
matter asserted so if it's an add a
court statement and the author of an
affidavit is not in court to be
cross-examined on that affidavit it's
not coming in
uh so
now a child that you could take a trial
deposition either by both parties
agreeing or by asking the court and that
can be brought in because they have the
opportunity to be cross-examined during
a deposition but uh just like a written
affidavit unless the person is allowed
to go in and testify
uh it can't come in in a lot of
jurisdictions they don't even allow
police reports to come in unless the
police officer is available and comes
into court to testify because uh
you're in a in the crucible of
cross-examination they don't just don't
allow some jurisdictions do allow police
reports some jurisdictions will allow
the police officer to testify
uh either via zoom or telephonically if
he's on duty or he's out out of town or
whatever but just a police reporter
alone without having the officer there
uh is usually not allowed in most
jurisdictions so apparently uh
winona ryder
and
um
vanessa paradise
uh said that johnny depp this is in the
news so
this is in media outlets this is not a
court document but they've but they've
stated publicly that
um like vanessa was with him for 14
years i don't know how long ryder was i
think was a few years but both of them
stated publicly that he was never
abusive and it's impossible to believe
her claims
right um okay well
again it's going to be up to the court
it'll be up to the judge to make a
ruling on the evidence what comes in and
what com is not allowed in
and i'm sure that
opposing counsel before the trial
started filed a motion in lemonae to try
to exclude testimony
from his former uh you know the mother
of his children and maybe winona ryder
and maybe kate moss and maybe others but
once heard testifies about any of those
people
now the door is open
uh to bring them in and have them submit
testimony or show up judge would
probably allow them to testify if
they're in california via zoom
i'd let the jury hear it so that that
was a good a good thing
uh that that uh herd kind of really
tripped up her own defense hey guys i
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the unplugged
alpha dot com forward slash shop when
you click through you'll be able to land
over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you